command the Seas with history's most
iconic war vessels in the latest free to
play combat game world of warships
download now hey guys it is the 28th of
sep tember today my name is Jess and you
are watching games buddies uncharted
developer Naughty Dog have come out to
explain why the upcoming uncharted
collection will not be including
PlayStation Vita entry golden Abyss the
studios community strategist on Maya
told power up gaming that wild the
game's inclusion in the Nathan Drake
collection was quote definitely under
consideration the studio decided that
the trilogy served as a better entry
into uncharted 4 on its own meijer
explained we realized that those three
games the trilogy actually provided a
particular narrative arc that led into
uncharted 4 we wanted to keep that as a
holistic collection for that reason and
golden the best kind of lives a little
bit outside of that golden abyss was
developed by SCE bend studio famous for
their Syphon Filter theories Naughty Dog
only supervised production of the Vita
title the Nathan Drake collection is due
out on october eight for ps4 rockstar
games has posted a number of job
listings which may allude to what the
studio has in store for us next as
discovered by gamesradar one listing
which calls for a gameplay designer at
Rockstar Toronto is calling for
qualifications including advanced
physical and digital prototyping skills
to establish the pillars of the
asymmetric cooperative stealth
experience the listing also mentions the
need for experience with destructible
environments as well as two new weapons
and physics a separate program a
position going at Rockstar HQ in New
York City involves research and
development for new animation technology
for use in our large FIFA World
character based games and finally while
they may or may not be busy recruiting
for their next big game it turns out
that rockstar might have never had
intention
to bring red dead redemption to the PC
that tidbit came via chris Roberts who
worked on the title as lead multiplayer
designer he explained I don't think
there was ever an intention to have a pc
version of red dead redemption as far as
the licensing for the consoles and stuff
it was pretty much always going to be an
xbox 360 and playstation 3 titles to the
best of my recollection we never even
seriously talked about optimizing it for
pc roberts also added that he was super
shocked to see that rockstar developed a
pc version of grand theft auto 5 let me
know down in that comment section what
kind of game you'd like to see rockstar
make next you can add two games but
we've got stories on a rise of the Tomb
Raider Xbox one bundle and what
uncharted Nathan Drake is used to look
like that is everything I have for you
today as always let me know what
mattered to you and I will catch you
same time tomorrow
[Music]